That's life.
Approximately 5,000 million years ago,
single-celled, the cell developed.
Specimens though we are,
we nonetheless retain many vestiges of our rapid development.
For example, the liquid in which our cells bathe
is almost identical to the seawater from which we originally come.
Fingers used to be fish fins.
Six is what remains of our monkey's tail.
Take the brain with its three layers.
The first layer we inherited from the reptiles.
The second, the Paleocortex, from the mammals.
And the third, the Neocortex, the most important, developed very rapidly.
It only took 500,000 years to form.
But of course, you already know all about that.
So if you'd like to, we'll move backwards.
Hey, where are you going? Stop at once. I said quads.
A little faster, please.
Right, we'll start again.
Here it is, then.
Primal soup, the source of all life.
The cell's engineer.
I'll put one here.
They're here.
genes are going to become chromosomes.
Oh dear, that's not very strong.
Oh, I have an idea.
Let's see how this will work.
Isn't that clever?
Come on, everybody!
Will it hold or won't it?
Yes, it will.
Won't it?
Genes have become chromosomes.
They will become the nucleus of the cell.
Mitochondria, which are probably ancient bacteria,
are surrounded by the cell which is forming.
A cell is born,
but it has to multiply if life is to develop.
Every living thing is composed of cells,
And the human body has 60,000,000 million of them.
The skin, the bones, the nerves and the muscles, the heart and the brain are all composed of cells.
Each one an independent living organism, breathes, produces energy, feeds itself and reproduces itself.
Size, one hundredth of a millimeter.
For a cell to be visible to the naked eye, the human body would have to be 500 meters tall.
And even then, it would be only the size of a pinhead.
This is tissue formed of cells.
Some salt. Does anyone need salt?
Minerals. Get your minerals here.
Glucocides over here. Come and get your glucocides.
Would you like some?
Yeah, lovely.
I'll take you to the cells.
Get away from here. We don't want any dust.
Carry on.
We need sugar immediately.
Add some fat, some proteins, and I think some water.
You heard what they did.
Traffic school paid proper attention to everything we were taught.
Don't rush work.
Come off, Fred.
Anything to report, Lieutenant?
Nothing, sir.
Keep well, Captain. Goodbye.
Here come the red blood corpuscles to bring us some oxygen.
Good, we need some.
Prefer doing that to carrying away the carbon dioxide.
Sigh there and see how a cell is made.
But how, Globin?
There's no window and we're too big to get in there.
But we red globules are cells as well, you know.
Lost our nucleus so we can't reproduce our cells like the others.
It's another load of carbon dioxide.
Standard.
They're now in the membrane that protects our cell, ladies and gentlemen.
And as you can probably see, it is composed mainly of proteins, fat, and sugar,
which are our protein assembly lines.
We have thousands and thousands of those.
Mitochondria, energy-producing centers.
They produce it by burning up all the food that is brought here.
And what is more, all our respiration comes from here too.
The centriole, the command post that controls the unity or the division of the cell.
This ribbon is the RNA messenger.
You see, it carries all the orders from the control center to the assembly line.
And the control center, it just so happens, is right there.
Our wonderful storage depots.
You know, we produce enough for export as well.
Destination at last, one of our lysosomes.
This is where you will be transformed.
A new life awaits you.
It's very sweet, too.
Soon, you'll be just like them.
Idiot!
What are you doing out of the way?
Service.
Will someone please tell me?
All we can do, Chief, we've tried everything, believe me.
Why don't you speed things up at the exits?
You can see they all jammed.
The assembly lines are saturated, Chief. They've asked us to slow down deliveries.
Things can't carry on like this. Send all the soplers to the fats immediately.
Come on, get rid of it.
Will someone please connect me to the maestro as soon as possible?
I have to speak to the maestro immediately.
The maestro is very busy right now.
I have to speak to him.
What's happening? What's going on?
What is it? I'm listening.
The maestro, he says, look, they're swamped with food.
They can only stock fats.
Something's got to be done.
And the other factories?
I'm afraid the situation is the same everywhere, maestro.
To do what's necessary.
Tell me, supervisor, are you asleep?
You're letting everybody come in.
Don't you know our factories are overflowing?
Of course she doesn't know.
It's up to me to know.
I'm the boss, after all.
Listen to me.
From this moment on, you're to stop all imports.
Nothing more comes in, do you hear?
Yes, sir.
Send me a neuron messenger.
Transmit this to the brain.
If they want to keep making fat up there, it's their business.
After all, the responsibility is theirs, you know.
But I don't want them to come and complain afterwards that they were not warned.
Anymore.
Say, please let me in.
I've been told they need me inside there today.
Through to sector 4,000, I want to speak to Lieutenant Jumbo Jr.
I've already spotted them, Captain.
Don't worry, no problem.
How everything's coming along today, shall we?
We need some sugar, yes, and some oxygen, of course, some water, some amino acids, all right, some proteins.
Lots of those, naturally, they make up half our body substance.
and I wonder why there's so much fat, that's odd.
Ah, a pinch of salt, that's good.
Well, all we have to do now is to hand over
to the membrane manager and remind him
that he must not forget--
- Sector 4000 calling all cells of Sector 4000.
Program the manufacture of collagen
and send it out as soon as it's ready, over and out.
- Hey, you there at headquarters, can't that order wait?
I'd far rather see to my own needs first, hmm?
- This is an entire system.
The skin has just been injured.
You know that orders for exports have priority.
Well, you heard what he said, didn't you?
Cancel everything and start again.
Chromosome room, an urgent order for collagen.
Send RNA messengers with the production blueprints to the production centers.
Got that? Then jump to it.
I'm in here, racking you lazy chromosomes!
Get to work at once!
What is it?
What's happening? Wait!
Oh, you must stop!
But once, you idiots,
said send the RNA messengers and you send the original DNA,
the base of our genetic capital.
Without that, how do you think we're going to reproduce ourselves?
Idiots!
Well, you heard what he said.
Will someone please...
You could have been so stupid!
Perishable, but that genetic capital is what links us with eternity.
Now, just make me a duplicate, a messenger.
And no mistakes this time, you imbeciles!
Here.
There you are.
...in one of our cells.
In one of our 60,000,000,000 cells.
Ready for dispatch. Send it.
The cell.
Its size...
One hundredth of a millimeter.
every day 500,000 million of them vanish
and are replaced at the rate of 50 million each second.